8 out of 10 women who are childless
didn't intend to be childless it's
called involuntary child listeners
around about 10 of women are physically
incapable of having kids for a variety
of reasons 10 said that they actually
didn't intend to have children and that
leaves a whopping four out of five who
didn't have children due to life
circumstances that's the most common
reason for it and the most common life
circumstance is leaving it too late to
find a partner and then have kids you
break through that fertility window on
the other side these women who get into
their 40s who always intended to have a
family who realize that they now can't
they go to support groups and these
women are grieving for families that
they never had which is just brutal like
to think that you can grieve for
something that didn't occur